oh i wonder if we can just sort of zoom
into the that that moment when you
decided that you're gonna get over the
cringe and make that youtube video make
that tick tock what was that experience
like yeah you know it was okay i i
hated the sound of my own voice so when
i would sort of listen back to them and
stuff
um some of them i just handed over to my
husband and said just press the button
and i'll sort of look this way and then
you know just didn't ever want to see it
again and
probably that's one of my methods
actually is just don't watch it back too
much because then you just become
critical and you want to make the
perfect video and actually it's better
off just saying
i know it's not perfect i might not look
or sound perfect but it's a useful
message so put it out there just in case
and then what you do is you get back
these messages from people saying
well thank you that really changed my
day or i'm using this with my son or
daughter and it's really helping thank
you and then you think well
yeah it's okay to put a non-perfect
video up there if you're being valuable
to someone so
that's sort of allowed me to
um
be imperfect yeah yeah and that that
kind of reminds me of the stuff you talk
about in motivation in in the book i
think it's maybe chapter two where you
say that it's really about like those
small steps and getting that feedback
and then that sustains the motivation
yeah it was that i guess that kind of
played into what kept you going in the
early days yeah and and in the book i
talk about that sort of need for
intrinsic motivation you know that sort
of we don't need uh you know they always
give stickers to kids now don't they at
schools and stuff
you know we don't need a sticker or a
trophy along the way we need uh
something inside of us that says yes
you're on the right track you're doing
the right thing and for me it was it was
that feeling that i get from
feedback from real people saying i used
it and it was helpful to me thank you um
and then there's that realization of you
know i can sit in one room with one
person at a time and try and be helpful
but when you can get
you know 100 messages back in a day that
say thank you that was really helpful
then
wow you know what an opportunity to
reach all those people were you worried
at all about your professional standing
when you started like yeah what was that
like this is a thing that all doctors
worry about as well so i i guess it's
the same yeah it's something i can ask
you as well actually because that was
probably the main thing in my mind was
oh what if someone i used to work with
sees this and what will they think of me
and and that sort of thing and and
you know somehow i managed to just do it
anyway but um
and actually the feedback i've got from
from old colleagues and staff has been
really positive you know sort of
colleagues who um
gps and stuff like that who say that
they you know mention the channel when
people are struggling and i think gosh
that that's
that's the compliment you want isn't it
is when people are willing to share your
stuff because they see it's valuable too
so and that's the sort of seal of
approval but there is just this moment
of almost free fall isn't it where you
think i'm gonna do it anyway and see
what happens and risk disapproval um but
i think i always had to stick to
that sense that
i'm doing it because i believe this
could be a useful thing for people yeah
i know there's this stuff that people
could have access to and um and we could
make it valuable for people so i had to
just sort of stick to my guns try and
maintain a sense of credibility all the
way along and
not just say anything you know do my
research and make sure that things were
grounded in
an evidence-based and stuff like that so
so that i believed in it yeah i think
that's that's really it's it's sort of
like um the whole simon sonic stuff the
whole start start with why thing like
when you have that core why behind what
you're doing it's not that you're trying
to get famous it's not that you're
trying to become a tick-tock celebrity
is that you're trying to educate people
on something that's genuinely useful
yeah i guess that is
oh you know that's the intrinsic
motivation rather than the extrinsic oh
i want to hit a million followers and
stuff like that yeah and it's it's
difficult because it it grabs you
doesn't and these platforms are made to
be
um addictive for creators as well as
users so there is a sense of oh how many
views did we get there or how many views
did we get there but always being able
to pull it back to
why did i make that video and actually
i've noticed that if i make a video
that i'm particularly pleased with
because it's valuable information i want
to share
i care a bit less about how many views
it gets because i think if i if that
video helps 10 people
um but only gets seen by you know 10 000
then that's that's worth it for me but
if if another video i make is not so
valuable but i'm doing it to try and get
views
then it's got less of a reward for me if
i um you know if i start to go down that
road yeah yeah it's exactly the same on
the youtube video thing like um
every creator i've ever spoken to has
this constant struggle between caring
about the numbers while simultaneously
not caring about the numbers how do you
how do you tell that line i just think
it's a tight rape isn't it and you
always have to just um
do a bit of a sort of mental check-in
every now and then
because i can tell if i start to go down
that road i mean
my husband is really that kind of side
of it so he'll look at numbers and say
oh this didn't do well that did well and
things like that but i feel that if i
get
um too into that then it's not good
because it really stumps creativity and
my ability to to think from from the
word go about what am i going to put
together to make a video with um you
know if i'm only thinking about views um
it's just so much harder to do the whole
thing hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day